بعد اقل من اسبوع من وصوله الى البيت
الابيض نفذ دونالد ترامب احد وعوده
الانتخابيه المثيره للجدل اقامه جدار عازل
على طول الحدود الجنوبيه للولايات المتحده
على ان تدفع المكسيك تكلفه بنائه وقع
ترامب قرارات تنفيذيه تقضي بالشروع في
بناء الجدار الذي قال انه سيحمي الولايات
المتحده ويوقف تدفق المهاجرين غير
الشرعيين والمخدرات ويمنع الجرائم مستشهدا
في ذلك بجدار الفصل العنصري الذي اقامته
اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه قرار اثار حفيظه
المسؤولين في المكسيك ودفع الرئيس انريكي
بينتا نيتو الى غاء زياره مقرره لواشنطن
والمطالبه بالتعامل باحترام مع بلاده فما
هي مالات الازمه بين امريكا ترامب
والمكسيك والى اي حد تؤشر على اسلوب
الرئيس ترامب في تسيير السياسه الخارجيه
المزيد في تقرير مراسلاتنا في واشنطن وجد
وقفي العلاقات الامريكيه المكسيكيه الى
تازم من الاسبوع الاول لدونالد ترامب في
الرئاسه فالقرار الذي اتخذه الرئيس
الامريكي لبناء جدار حدود مع المكسيك بهدف
منع تسلل المهاجرين غير الشرعيين فجر ازمه
دبلوماسيه بين البلدين حتى قبل ثبوت تعيين
وزير خارجيه في اداره ترامب ما يبين حرصه
على ان يظهر على انه رئيس يوفي بوعوده
الانتخابيه حتى لو تم ذلك بشكل متهور كما
يرى مراقبون اما مصدر الهام ترامب لبناء
الجدار مع المكسيك فهو
اسرائيل الجدران فعاله كل ما عليكم فعله
للتحقق هو سؤال اسرائيل عنها الجدران
فعاله اذا بنيت جيدا وتم تحصينها امنيا
لكن لن يحل الجدار مشكله ترامب فنحو 40%
من المهاجرين غير الشرعيين يصلون الى
امريكا جوا هذه الفلسفه لترامب سببت
تدهورا سريعا للعلاقات مع المكسيك خلال
ثلاثه ايام فقط فالرجل يريد ان تتحمل
الجاره تكلفه الجدار التي تصل الى 15
مليار دولار تجلى ذلك في تغريده له على
تويتر مفادها ان الرئيس المكسيكي غير مرحب
به ان لم تتحمل بلاده الاعباء الماديه
للجدار فما كان من الرئيس انريكي بين نيتو
الا الغاء الزياره الى واشنطن التي كانت
مقرره له للقاء ترامب الثلاثاء المقبل
فردت اداره ترامب على لسان المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض بانه يفكر في فرض ضرائب على
الواردات
المكسيكيه لكن في حال نفذت واشنطن تهديدها
فان نحو 5ه ملايين امريكي سيخسر
وظائفهم لقد انتقد جمهوريون بينهم م ترومن
مزاجيه ترامب ما لا نعرفه وما اذا كان
بالفعل رجلا مندفعا ومته او انه يعرف شيئا
نجهله عن السياسه الامريكيه المؤكد حتى
اللحظه ان الوضع فوضوي واذا نفذت الاداره
الامريكيه تهديدا اخر وهو الغاء اتفاقيه
تبادل التجاره الحره لدول امريكا الشماليه
التي تشمل المكسيك وكندا فان ذلك سيحمل
عواقب اقتصاديه وخيمه ليس على المكسيكي
وحسب ايضا على الولايات المتحده التي
يربطها بالمكسيك تبادل تجاري تتجاوز قيمته
530 مليار دولار ما يضع المكسيك في
المرتبه الثالثه بعد كندا والصين من حيث
حجم الشراكه التجاريه ويخشى منتقد ترامب
من ان تسيطر انفعالاته على قراراته فينجم
عنها سياسات هوجاء قد تهز رؤيته بان تكون
امريكا اولا وجد وقفي الجزيره واشنطن
وينضم الينا من من واشنطن كل من الدكتور
محمد الشرقاوي استاذ تسويه النزاعات
الدوليه والسياسات العامه في جامعه جورج
مسن وويليام دانفرز كبير البحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي والخبير في شؤون الامن
القومي دكتور محمد الشرقاوي اذا لا يبدو
تعهد ترامب ببناء جدار مع المكسيك تعهدا
خلبي ضمن حمله انتخابيه ها هو ينفذ
وعوده اعتقد ان المشكله ليست فقط في عزم
وبناء الجدار بل ايضا في فرض تعريفات
جمركيه بين نسبه 20% على الواردات
المكسيكيه الى الولايات المتحده وهذا في
حد ذاته يشكل اعلان حرب تجاريه على اقرب
جيرانه من ناحيه الجنوب المشكله ايضا انه
يعني يعاني او يشكو من كثره الفائض او
العجز التجاري الامريكي مع المكسيك في
حدود 58 مليار دولار لكنه لا يقول شيئا عن
العجز التجاري الامريكي مع الصين وهو في
حدود 362 ملي ميار دولار فالان يبدو
ان مستقبل النفطه او اتفاقيه التجاره
الحره بين المكسيك والولايات المتحده
وكندا اصبحت في مهب الريح واصبحنا الان
نلاحظ يعني تصعيد في اللهجه وخروج عن
دبلوماسيه العلاقات الدوليه يعني ترامب
يريد ان يعصف بهذه العلاقات مع المكسيك عن
طريق تغريدات ويلغي الاجتماع ويدفع الان
الاخطر ما اراه من منطق النزاع هو ان هناك
الان تغدي التيار القومي الابيض في امريكا
وايضا
التيار في كل هذه النقاط دكتور محمد في
سياق اسئلتنا القادمه ولكن سيد ويام
دانفرز هناك تساؤل لماذا ذهب ترامب مباشره
الى هذا الحد في التصعيد مع المكسيك رغم
ان المسار التفاوضي كان متاحا بوجود وزيري
الخارجيه والاقتصاد في
واشنطن س هناك اي سبب عقلاني يدفع ترامب
للتعاطي مع هكذا موضوع بهذه
الطريقه الحجره طبعا تحدي كبير ما بين
الولايات المتحده والمكسيك وبامكان حل هذا
المشكل من خلال المفاوضات ونقاش وبمكان
التعاطي مع هذا الملف ايضا من الناحيه
الداخليه ومكاني ان اقول وكل شخص في
الولايات المتحده هو من خارج الولايات
المتحده وزوجتي من خارج المحده جدي من
خارج الولايات المتحده اذا بالنسبه للهجره
فهذا شيء يثري ويغني الولايات المتحده اذا
لا اعتقد بان هذه هي المقاربه الصحيحه
لتعاطي مع موضوع الهجره هذا هو الطريق
الخاطئ بالامكان نتعاطي مع هذا الملف
بطريقه مثمره ومنتجه نسال دكتور محمد
الشرقاوي براي هل سيحل هذا الجدار ان بني
مساله الهجره غير
الشرعيه لا يمكن لان الهجره لا تتم عبر
الجدار وحده بل هناك ايضا الانفاق وايضا
المطارات واعتقد ان ترامب تصميم على بناء
الجدار ربما يتخلف عن ركب التاريخ لان
الجدران قد تبدو للعيان وكانها يعني فعاله
لكن من ناحيه اذا درسنا الاحصائيات
وارتفاع معدل الهجره غير الشرعيه الجدار
يفقد ا يعني صوابه هناك ايضا ترامب فيذه
الخطوه اليوم ينطبق عليه القول يعني شوت
ست ان سك بمعنى اطلق الرصاص اولا ثم صوب
هدفك فيما بعد لماذا لانه يبدو اذا مضى
قدما في فرض 20% على الواردات المكسيكيه
هذا سيعصف بحوالي 6 ملايين وظيفه
ويهدد 40 مليون وظيفه اخرى بشكل غير مباشر
الاكثر من هذا هناك الان قلق متزايد لان
اغلب الواردات المكسيكيه اذا فرضت عليها
التعريف فات الجمركيه سيرتفع سعرها في
الاسواق وستضرب جيوب المستهلكين
الامريكيين ومنهم العمال والفلاحين والذين
صوتوا له في الحمله الانتخابيه فيبدو ان
هناك نوع من التناقض الداخلي داخل هذا
المنطق الترامبي الذي يعتد باستخدام القوه
بشكل علني لكنه لا يتريت ولا يتمهل في
دراسه العواقب سواء قصيره المدى او طويله
المدى في خساره الورقه المكسيكيه في هذه
المرحله سيد ويم دانفرز هل سيقتصر تعاطي
امريكا ترامب مع الدول والمكسيك من بينها
من المنظور التجاري بعيدا عن المنظورين
الاستراتيجي والامني الذين يمكن ان يكونا
احيانا اكثر اهميه ربما من المنظور
التجاري كل هذه المجالات هامه التجاره
والامن القومي هامه اي اريد ان اعلق سريعا
حول نقطه مهمه
ذكرها الضيف الاخر نعم اتفق مع كل ما قاله
وان الجدار لن يكون فعالا اريد ان اقول
بان في حقيقه الامر ان الولايات المتحده
ايضا تتسبب في الكثير من المشاكل لمكسيك
وهناك الكثير من الناس الذين يغادرون ايضا
الولايات المتحده باتجاه المكسيك هذه
النقطه اذا الرئيس الامريكي الجديد لا
يستوعب تفاصيل الموضوع كامله واعتقد ان
هذه الخطوه طبعا ستضر لا محال بالامن
القومي للبلدين
والتعامل باخوه وصداقه مع الجيران هو من
شانه ان يعزز الامن والسلامه في البلدين
طبعا ان ندر الان بالعلاقات التجاريه هذا
شيء لا معنى له عندما يتم الرفع التعريفات
الجمركيه ب 20% فهذا مدرب بالتاكيد للجم
نعم هذا مدر بالمستهلك الامريكي وايضا بال
المكسيكيين ربما بعض الشركات ستستفيد ولكن
كما قلت المكسيك لن تدفع تكاليف الجدار
ولا اعتقد ان على المكسيك ان تدفع تكاليف
الجدار وهذا الامر اعتقد انه بعيد عن ال
دكتور محمد الشرقاوي بعيدا عن المكسيك هل
يريد ترامب توجيه رساله الى الدول الاخرى
عن مدى صرامته في تطبيق وعوده
وقراراته لا شك انه يكرس نرجسيه الرجل
القوي الذي يريد ان يطلع من كل مفاوضات
وهو الفائز والرابح الوحيد ما نقراه الان
في موقفه وتعامله مع المكسيك هو يعني ينم
عن قناعه مترسخ لديه بانه يريد ان يتحلل
من كل كل الاتفاقيات الاقتصاديه سواء كانت
اتفاقيه دول المحيط الهادي او اتفاقيه
النفطه يريد ان يتعامل بانفراد العلاقات
مع كل دوله على حده هو يريد اعاده بناء
العلاقه مع كندا اعاده التفاوض بشان
النفطه فيبدو ان منطق اداره الاعمال
وابرام الصفقات الذي يعتقد انه هو الانجح
فيه عالميا يريد ان يكرسه في المجال
الدبلوماسي في المجال السياسي و اعتقد ان
منطق العقارات لا يتفق الى حد كبير مع
منطق السياسه الدوليه وخاصه وان الان يعني
مستقبل النافه هو يضر بالمصانع الامريكيه
وبالايد العامله الامريكيه اكثر من الايدي
العامله المكسيكيه اود ان اضيف نقطه
اساسيه هو لا يدرك حقيقه انه اذا دفع
المكسيك الى ايقاف واردتها الزراعيه
والاليه وما الى ذلك سوف يخلق ازمه بطاله
داخل المكسيك ماذا سيحدث بعد ذلك سترتفع
مستويات الهجره الشرعيه الى الولايات
المتحده فللاسف هو يعني يتخذ خطوات لكنها
خطوات تاتي بمضاعفات عكسيه ولا ينتبه
ويبدو الان انه ربما يحتاج ليومين على
الاقل ليعيد النظر في موضوع التعريفات
الجمركيه بنسبه 20% سيد دانفرز دكتور محمد
الشرقاوي لم يبدو مطمئن بالنسبه لمستقبل
نافته في اطار الحديث عن طلب ترامب اعاده
التفاوض بشانها كيف تراه
انت اتمنى اتمنى انلا يحدث الامر طبعا
الدكتور الشرقاوي له تحليل
بعيد الرؤيه واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
للاسف مع هذا الرئيس الجديد تمضي في اتجاه
خاطئ واتمنى لا تحدث هذه الامور لان هذا
لن يكون في صالح الولايات المتحده ان
ينسحب طرف من اتفاقيات تم توقع فتره بعيده
فهذا لا يعطي اشارات مشجعه وكما تفضل
الدكتور الشرقاوي فحوالي خمس الى 6 ملايين
مناصب شغل في امريكا تعتمد على هذا على
الفته واعتقد ان الامريكي لن يكونوا
متحمسين لخطوات
بهذا بهذا الحجم ولن يفيد هذا الاقتصاد
الامريكي على الاطلاق علاوه على ذلك وهذه
نقطه اساسيه يجب ان
نتذكرها ما ياتي من المكسيك من منتجات
هناك نسبه من هذه
المنتجات لها قيمه مضافه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عندما يتم استيراد الشيء فهناك
بعض الامور التي كانت قد ذهبت من الولايات
المتحده اما التصميم او بعض اجزاء المنتج
اذا اعتقد ان هذا سيكون مدرا بشكل كبير
للولايات المتحده انا عملته في م لمنظمه
الاو سي دي في باريس واعلم بان هناك
الكثير من المنتجات التي تصدر البلدان
معينه ولكن الكثير من اجزاء هذه المنتجات
قادمه من البلدان التي تصدر اليها دكتور
محمد الشرقاوي هذه الازمه تفاقمت جراء
تغريده هل سيستمر ترامب بتغريداته هذه
وبالتالي بازمات
ايضا ما بين يوم الانتخاب ويوم نصيب كنا
نتمنى وننتظر ان يغير ترامب سلوك هو ان
يتقبل نصيحه مستشاريه بمعنى الابتعاد عن
التغريدات والتعامل مع الدول الاخرى عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه كنت اتحدث مع بعض
المسؤولين في الخارجيه وهم الان يعيشون في
مرحله الغموض لا احد يكلمهم ولا احد يتصل
بهم وهم الان يعني غير رادون و غير رادين
على هذا المسلك الشخصي لانه يبدو انه متها
متسارع واعتقد انه سيسقط في العديد من
المطبات ثم يترك فريقه
وبقيه المسؤولين في وزاره الخارجيه هم من
يصلحون فللاسف الرجل يعني بدل بدل ان يبني
خطوه الى الامام ربما سيضع الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه خطوتين الى الوراء و سنشهد
مرحله تصحيح و تصحيح يبدو ان التويت او
التغريدات هي من اساليبه ولا يمكن اعتقد
انه س اشكر اذا
ح اشكرك جزيلا دكتور محمد الشرقاوي استاذ
تسويه النزاعات الدوليه والسياسات العامه
في جامعه جورج ميسون وويليام دانفرز كبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي والخبير
في شؤون الامن القومي شكرا لمتابعه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء